Now, with that said, let's go into the
meat of the matter. Let's go into the
meat of the matter. Are we ready? What
is saving faith? But here it is. And you
can thank him for this post. All right.
I wrote this post for you guys. Now,
watch here. Here's the article, guys, in
the description box. He tried to accuse
me of perverting the meaning of
faith when I said that faith is to be
faithful. And you can't be faithful
without obedience. But because he's a
Bible pervert, he doesn't know
scripture. I'm now going to shish kebab
him, right? And skewer him even though
he's he's shaped like a skewer. Does the
Bible define saving faith as obedience
to our
Lord? Does the Bible define saving faith
as obedience to our Lord? Are we ready
now? Now watch. I'm going to be quoting
Protestant exedites to see what it
means. All right.
Let's go here. Through him, we have
received grace and our apostilhip to
bring about the obedience of faith. Did
you catch it? It's right there. Black
and
white. There is no such thing as saving
faith that's not obedient faith. That's
not a
faith that results in and is being
obedient to our Lord. May the Holy
Spirit save me from error. You caught
it.
Do you see right there? And I'm going to
let the Protestant exedites exedute the
meaning, the obedience of
faith. You see it
here, the obedience of faith. So what
I'm going to show here, the God breathe
scriptures define true saving faith as
being obedient to God, which comes on by
obeying his commands. It's not faith and
works salvation. See, this is what they
don't get because you let them get away
with murder. What do I mean? You let
them get away with
murder. You're letting them define faith
for you in such a way that
faith is merely mental
ascent. Whereas the Bible defines faith
as
faithfulness, being a faithful covenant
partner. And there is no such thing as
being faithful that isn't being obedient
to your covenant
partner. Are you with me
there? So when you let them tell you you
preach faith and work salvation say no
you are a son of Satan. You don't know
what faith is because if I go with your
definition even believing in Christ is a
work. So now you just distinguish faith
from belief, but I thought faith is to
believe. What do I mean? Watch it.
Follow me. We're going to do series on
this. Trusting the spirit to illuminate
me because he brought me out of the
false gospel of Martin Lucifer, which
they still embrace
here. Remember faith and works,
right? Faith and works, right? Well,
then belief can't be faith. That means
belief is something different from faith
because believing is working. How do I
know? Okay, watch here. John 6:27 29 29.
Do not work for the food. Notice, work,
work for the food which perishes, but
for the food which endures to eternal
life, which the son of man will give to
you. For on him the
Father, God set a seal. Therefore, they
said to him, "What should we do so that
we may work the works of God?" Notice,
it's about working, doing, not simply
affirming or believing in the heart.
Jesus answered and said to them, "This
is the work of God that you believe in
him who has whom he has sent." Now, we
got a problem. Now, if you define faith
as something that is distinct from works
as opposed to define faith as being
faithful to your covenant partner and
there is no
faithfulness that isn't obeying your
covenant partner. Now we got a
problem because now believing is a work.
So now I can tell the idiots who think
they know the Bible, you
preach faith and works when you say
faith in Christ and believing in him.
You see how stupid that
sounds? You see how stupid that
sounds? It's right here. Belief is a
work. Therefore, if I say, do I have to
believe in Christ? Yeah. Oh, work
salvation. Why? Because
believing is a work you must do. But
then if they tell me, well, believing is
the same as faith. Oh, then that means
faith is a
work. You see how you bury them?
Understand the argument. This is why I
say the guy's a kid. He's too stupid.
He'll get clobbered and pulverized if he
debates. So if they tell you no dummy,
believing
is to have faith. To have faith is to
believe. That means faith is a work. So
therefore, when you say you're saved by
faith, you're now saying you're saved by
works. You false Christian, you're
preaching a false gospel. See how stupid
this is?
Do you guys see it here or you don't see
it? It's right here in front of you.
Either way they answer, it's a burial.
They don't know the Bible. Let's move on
and ignore them. They want attention to
get views. Shame on you for making them
popular. I want you to understand this
argument. right here, black and white,
it says believing is a work. If they
want to say faith and believing are
synonymous, it's one and the same. They
just admit faith is a work. Therefore,
what they're telling you is you're saved
by
works. But if faith and believing are
not
synonymous, right? Having faith and
believing have nuance shades of meaning
than to say believing in Christ it's
required for salvation saying you need
to work for your
salvation you with me
there did everyone get it before I move
on this always shove it down their
throats my point is if you define faith
in such a way that goes against how the
Bible defines it. How does the Bible
define faith? Faith is being faithful to
your covenant partner. It's not mental
ascent. That is the faith condemned to
hell by James. Once you understand faith
is being faithful to your covenant
partner. That
faith all right
encompasses subsumes working because
there is no faith that's not working.
There's no faith that's not being
faithful to your covenant partner. You
can't be faithful without obeying. Why
do you think Paul says he was sent to
preach to the Gentiles and get the
Gentiles to do
what? To do
this. Watch here. To bring about the
obedience of
faith. And again to show you these Bible
butcherers do not know the Bible. Watch
here. They tell you believe in Christ,
right? No, that's not enough to be
saved. How do I know? Paul says in front
of your eyes. Paul says in front of your
eyes that if you confess with your mouth
Jesus is Lord and believe in your heart
that God raised him from the dead,
you'll be saved. Why don't they focus on
this? Belief in your heart is not enough
to save you. You must do something. Use
your mouth to say
something. What part of Paul do you guys
not
understand? Hold on, brethren. Paul says
you must do something with your mouth.
Confess with your mouth Jesus is Lord,
not just believe in your
heart. Oh, so Paul taught faith and
works.
You guys catch it
here? You see it? I just quoted it,
brother. I'm just giving you a
scripture. Yes, Nick. I'll get there,
brother. I'll get there. But I want to
go to what faith is. For with the heart
a person believes, leading to
righteousness, and with the mouth he
confesses, leading to salvation. Wait,
it's your confession that saves you, not
just your belief in your
heart. Which part of the gospel you guys
don't get? Yes, he's against Catholics
and Orthodox. He even when he talks
about Catholics, he distinguishes them
from Christians. All
right. All right. Did everyone get it
here? Did we get it?
Mega, are you getting
it? Am I going with church tradition or
I'm quoting
scripture? Am I going with tradition or
quoting scripture which itself is a
tradition passed on to us? What must you
do to be saved? Confess with your
mouth. Because it is the confession with
mouth that results in salvation. Not
just believing. It's not enough to
believe. You must confess. Also, Paul
taught faith and
works. Faith and works. Right? Did
everyone get it? I don't want to move on
if you don't get this. So, two facts to
begin with. It is not enough to believe.
You must confess. Do something with your
mouth. That's what Paul said. You must
confess with your
mouth. That confession will result in
belief in your heart. Because if you
don't believe in your heart, you're not
going to confess. But you must do
something. Confess to be saved.